[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعصيف الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى نبدا من واشنطن والخبر
الرئيسي فيها في الساعات الماضيه هو تبادل
لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه التي كانت
سجينه في روسيا بريتني براينر مقابل
الافراج عن رجل الاعمال الروسي فيكتور بوت
وفي موسكو ينتظروا وصول بوت الذي كان رهن
الاحتجاج في الولايات المتحده منذ اربعه
اعوام بتهمه بيع السلاح لحركه متمرده في
كولومبيا
ومن رام الله تريدنا هذه الصور في يوم دام
اخر سقط فيه خمسه شهداء واصيب اخرون برصاص
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
واستقطيعه دبلوماسيه جراء الحربي في
اوكرانيا امريكا وروسيا تتبادلان السجناء
لاعبه كره سله امريكيه مقابل رجل اعمال
روسي
على اطلاق مزيدا من السجناء في روسيا دون
تغيير في موقفها من الحرب على اوكرانيا
هم كانوا يمتنعون عن الحوار
غاده الاعلان عن احباط مخطط انقلابي لحركه
مواطن الرايخ الشرطه الالمانيه تدهم 150
موقعا جديدا والاستخبارات تقول الى معظمه
منتسبي التنظيم جنود سابقون وان بعض
اسلحتهم من مخازن الجيش
على وقع توسيع القوات التركيه لاهدافها في
شمال سوريا مصادر تركيه تقول للجزيره ان
انقره تبحث مقترحات عرضها الوفد الروسي
تشمل انسحاب قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
باسلحتها من عين العرب ومنبج اشاره ضماني
عدم تنفيذ العمليات البريه
في موجه اقتحامات جديده للضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتل خمسه
فلسطينيين
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه تتهم اسرائيل بالسعي
لاشعال المنطقه وحماس تعلن التمسك بخيار
المقاومه
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا سقوط خمسه شهداء فلسطينيين
برصاصه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ثلاثه
منهم في مدينه جنين ورابع في بلده سلواد
بينما استشهد الفلسطيني الخامس قرب قريتي
عابود شمال غرب رام الله وقالت الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه الى اسرائيل تحاول اشعالا
منطقه من خلال مواصله جرائمها بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني كما قالت حماس الى ما حدث جريمه
واستمرار لحرب اسرائيل المفتوحه على الشعب
الفلسطيني لاستطاعه ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع وكنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في نظركم ما هي دوافع التصعيد
الاسرائيلي الجديد في الضفه الغربيه
35% قالوا ان الدوافع الرئيسيه هي تهيئه
الاجواء لتصعيدا اكبر بينما ادراجها
ثلاثون في البيئه في اطار المزيدات بين
القاده الاسرائيليين ورجح 35% ان العم ذات
الحاليه تنفيذ لسياسات المتطرفين في
اسرائيل هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
بعض الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه عشر دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات
المونديال التي ترصد بالخبر والتحليل
مباريات كاس العالم قطر 2002 2010
[موسيقى]
الخلاف بين واشنطن وموسكو بشان حرب روسيا
في اوكرانيا لم يمنع الجانبين من الوصول
الاتفاق لتبادل السجناء بينهما افرج عن
لعيبه كره السله الامريكيه بريتنير في
مقابل اطلاقه رجل الاعمال الروسي فيكتور
بوت وقال الرئيس الامريكي جو بعيدا ان
ادارته عامله منذ فتره طويله من اجل هذا
اليوم واوضح ان اعاده الامريكيين الى
وطنهم واجبه وليست اختياريه وان الاداره
الحاليه اعاده الكثير من الامريكيين الذين
اعتقلوا او خطوه
ابراهيم ابراهيم
الذين اعتقلوا او اختطفوا خارج الولايات
المتحده اليوم ايضا نتذكر الامريكيين
الاخرين الذين تم احتجاجهم كرها في روسيا
واماكن اخرى حول العالم اعاده هؤلاء
الامريكيين الى عائلتهم ستظل اولويه نار
سنواصل العمل على اعاده كل امريكي
اضافه بعيدا ان ادارته ستواصل التفاوض مع
روسيا بنيه حسنه وستواصل العمل من اجل
اعاده الامريكيه المعتقل في روسيا
بولولاند واكد بايظ ان موسكو تتعامل مع
قضيه بولويلان بشكل مختلف عن قضيه جريلر
المعتقل في روسيا دون سبب منذ سنوات اعاده
الامريكيين الى وطنهم امر واجب وليست امرا
اختياريا لقد عدنا الى الوطن
خلال هذا العام للاسف تتعامل روسيا مع
قضيه بولويلان بشكل المغاير عن قضيه
بريتني لن نتخلى عن محاولاتنا وسنبقى على
تواصل مستمر مع عائله البول وسن واصل
التفاوض بحسن نيه من اجل اطلاق الصراحه
اضمن لكم ذلك نيويورك
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني بلنكن
ان واشنطن كانت امام خياري اطلاق سراح
سجينا واحدا او لا احد وذلك خلال
مفاوضاتها مع روسيا بشان تبادل السجناء
واكدب لينكين في مؤتمر صحفي عقده مع نظيره
الفنلندي والسويدي في واشنطن ان بلاده
ستواصل بذله كل ما في وسعها لاعاده
مواطنها بول ويلن الذي تتهم روسيا بالتجسس
على ارض الوطن
امير امير
وبحثنا الطرائق المختلفه لتنفيذ واعني
بذلك اعاده كل من بريتنه وبول كنا امام
خيارين في المفاوضات مع الروس اما اطلاق
سراح سجين واحد او لا احد لانه هو للاسف
في استمرت روسيا في اعتبار قضيه تجسس
وتتعامل معه بطريقه تختلف عن طريقه
تعاملها مع بريك كل ما في وسعينا للافراج
لكن ليست هناك طريقه لاعادته في هذه
اللحظه
قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم جون
بيار ان الولايات المتحده وروسيا وحدهما
تفاوضتا من اجل الافراج عن لعيبه كره
السله الامريكيه بريتني جرايدر وانه لم
تكن هناك اي وساطه من دول اخرى واعربت
خلال مؤتمرها الصحفي اليوم عن امتنان
الولايات المتحده للامارات لتسهيلها
استخدام اراضيها لاجراء تبادل السجناء و
لدول اخرى منها السعوديه التي اثارت قضيه
الامريكيين المحتجزين ظلما مع الحكومه
الروسيه حسب تعبير المتحدثه
قال بيان المشترك اماراتي سعودي ان وساطه
قادها رئيس دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
الشيخ محمد بن زايد والامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد السعودي قد نجحت في الافراج عن
مسجونين اثنين بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا وتبادلهما رجاء في البيان المشترك
لوزرتي خارجيه السعوديه والامارات ان نجاح
جهود الوساطه ياتي انعكاسا لعلاقات
الصداقه المشتركه والوطيده التي تجمع
بلديه ما بالولايات المتحده وروسيا وكذلك
للدوري المهم الذي تلعب قياده البلدين في
تعزيز الحوار بين جميع الاطراف بحسب
مبارده في البيان الذي اشار ايضا الى ان
ابو ظبي استقبلت المواطنه الامريكيه
بريتني جراينر عبر طائره خاصه من موسكو
بالتزامنه مع استقبال المواطن الروسي
فيكتور بوت عبره طائره خاصه من واشنطن
تفاصيل اخرى لعمليه تبادل السجينين وما
تمثله في اطار العلاقات المتوتره بين
روسيا والولايات المتحده في التقرير
التالي
من الاتصالات السريه وبعيدا عن الاعلام
نضجت صفقه التبادل لاعبه كره السله
الامريكيه بريتني جراينر مقابل التاجيل
السلاح الروسي فيكتور فود
31 عاما اعتقلت في مطار موسكو شهره فبراير
الماضي بتهمه حيازه كميه من المخدرات
ولاحقا فيها اغسطس قضت محكمه روسيه بسجنها
تسع سنوات اما بوت ذو الخمسه 55 عاما
والملقب بتاجر الموت فقد اوقف في تايلاند
عام 2008 ثم سلم الى الولايات المتحده
التي حكمت عليه بخمسه وعشرين عاما سجنا
بتهمه تهريب اسلحه الى منظمه القوات
المسلحه الثوريه كولومبيه المعروفه
اختصارا بفارك والتي تعتبرها واشنطن منظمه
ارهابيه
في واشنطن سبقت اخبار الصفقه الاعلان عنها
في موسكو لكن العاصمتين اقرتان بان
التبادل جاء تتويجا لمفاوضات صعبه وشاقه
قالت الخارجيه الروسيه انها عملت بنشاط
لانقاذ المواطن الروسي رغم رفض الولايات
المتحده في البدء ادراجه ضمن اليه التبادل
اما الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن فسارع الى
مهاتفه بريتني وهي في طريقها جوا الى
الولايات المتحده
العشرات من الامريكيين الذين اعتقلوا
اختطفوا خارج الولايات المتحده اليوم ايضا
نتذكر الامريكيين الاخرين الذين تم
احتجاجهم كرهان في روسيا واماكن اخرى حول
العالم
اعاده هؤلاء الامريكيين الى عائلاتهم ستظل
اولويه سنواصل العمل على اعاده كل امريكي
ما زال يتعرض لهذا الظلم
لكن الانجازات
لم تشمل الجنديه السابق بمشاه البحريه بول
ويلن المعتقله في روسيا منذ 2016 وهو يقضي
عقوبه بالسجن 16 عاما بتهمه التجسس وقد
تعهد بايدا بعدم التخلي عنه وبمواصله
المساعي حتى اخلاء سبيله
والواضح ان هذا الاختراق الامريكيه الروسي
في ملف السجناء ياتي بعيده نجاح
الديمقراطيين لانتخابات التجديد النصفي
كان انه لا ينفصل عن تلك الاتصالات غير
المنقطع بين البلدين والتي كشف عنها اخيرا
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي وبررها
بضروره اداره النزاع وكبح المخاطر
الاستراتيجيه العالميه
تنضم الينا من البيت الابيض مراسله
الجزيره وجد وقفي وجد ماذا في اخر ما سجل
من مواقف وردود فعل حول اتمام صفقه
التبادل
ردود الفعل جاءت بالتساؤل عن سبب عدم
التمكن من اطلاق سراح طويلا هذا ما ورد في
معظم اسئله صحفيين خلال الاحاطه التي
قدمتها المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض وكذلك
في مواقف عدد من اعضاء الكونجرس تحديدا
الجمهوريين مثل جمهوريش وهو كبير
الجمهوريين في رجل العلاقات الخارجيه بمجد
الشيوخ الذي قال كان من المفترض او ينبغي
ايضا ضمان اطلاق سراح ويلا ولكن كما قالت
كارين جون بير المتحدثه باسم ال البيت
الابيض ان هذا القرار كان ثقيلا على
الرئيس الامريكي وذلك ان الولايات المتحده
اولا كانت امام خيار واحد وهو اما ان يتم
اطلاق صراحه صراحه بيتني وتعود سالمه الى
الولايات المتحده او لا احد وكررت هذه
العباره كثيرا خلال الاحاطه والقرار يعني
هو طبيعه عمل همم فيكتور بوت تاجر السلاح
ويسمى امريكيا بانه تاجر الموت تابوت كان
قد امضى اثني عشر عاما هنا في السجون في
السجن في الولايات المتحده
وكان من المفترض ان يطلق سراحه في عام
2029 ولكن طبعا تم اطلاق سريعه بموجب هذه
الصفقه الاداره الامريكيه تعلم الثمن
باطلاق سراحي ولكن كان هو الخيار الوحيد
اما اطلاق صراحه مقابل بريطني او عدم عوده
اي مواطن امريكي من الموجودين في روسيا
هذا على صعيد تبرير سبب عدم تمكن من اطلاق
سراح ويلا حتى الان البيت الابيض حرص على
التواصل مع عائله وقد تم ذلك همم امس
تواصل معه مسؤول مع العائله مسؤولون
امريكيون ليحذروهم بانه لن يتم اطلاق سراح
ويلا في اي وقت قريب وبانى فقط
التي سوف تعود الى الولايات المتحده
وبمناسبه هي في طريق العوده الى الولايات
المتحده البيت الابيض رفض منحنى موعدا
لوصول طائراتها او ما اذا كانت ستصل
طائراتها الى واشنطن ام الى ولاياتها همم
تكساس وذلك لاسباب امنيه ولكن الاداره
الامريكيه تؤكد بان الجهود المبنيه من اجل
ضمان اطلاق سراح ويلا ما تزال مستمره وهي
مستمره منذ ان زوج به في السجن في روسيا
منذ عام
2018 ولكن همم عوده بريتني كانت الخيال
الوحيد امام هذه الاداره الامريكيه التي
اضطرت للقبول بالطلب الروسي واطلاق
فيكتوريا فيكتور بوت مقابل همم
بريتني شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الساعه وجد وقفي
مراسيلتنا من البيت الابيض
للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع معنا
فيدوروف عضو مجلس الدومه الروسي ومن
واشنطن بيجي كراولي المتحدث السابق باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه مرحبا بكما
يفجاني فودروف ماده واسعه التي شجعت روسي
على الانخراط في هذه الصفقه
مع حقوق الانسان هذا اهم من اي شيء هذا هو
موقفنا المستمر وكان السيد بوت قد اسر
وحجز بطريقه غير قانونيه في امريكا كعمليه
استفزازيه وروسيا كانت قد
التقت مع الشركاء الامريكيين الا ان هذا
اساس في العلاقات الخارجيه الروسيه وسوف
نستمر بهذا مع الولايات المتحده نحن لدينا
حوار كما ترون مع الامريكيين وهذا دليل
على ان هذه هذا هو الاساس لل- اا احداث
التي سوف تستمر حتى في اوكرانيا
هل هي فقط لتامين اطلاق صراحه
اه جمهوريه
بسيطه
جندي سابق في المرينز
وقت انت كويس
اوضحوا ان التغيير سيكون بين هذين الشخصين
ولا احد غيرهما
وهذا لا علاقه له بحقوق الانسان ولا
الشراكه انه ابتزاز لا اكثر
نقعد شويه
هذه صفقه تبادل طبيعيه ان الانسان يقيم في
روسيا تمام كما يقيم في امريكا اييي مواطن
امريكي واحد مقابل
مواطن روسي واحد ايضا
وهنا يجب ان نستمر باي
مفاوضات لاي تبادل في المستقبل واحد مقابل
واحد لن نقوم بتبديل اعداد كبيران همم
مقابل شخص واحد المهم هنا ان ان يستمر
الحوار بيننا وبين امريكا حتى وان كانت
سريه ويجب ان نستمر بالاتفاق عن طريق هذه
القناه القنوات
مع الامريكيين ولكن البيت الابيض كان
واضحا اليوم ان السياسه سياسه دعم
اوكرانيا لن تتغير
مفهوم جيدا لان الولايات المتحده ليست تحت
التهديد ولكن الولايات المتحده هي من تقدم
الاسلحه والمعلومات للاوكران وبعض الجنود
كالخبراء وهم يهددوننا
وتغيير
الامن الصعب كان هناك غلط من طرفنا عندما
توقفنا عن التدريبات العسكريه بيننا وبين
امريكا
بشكل اخر يجب ان يقول ان الامن المشترك
يجب ان يكون فيه الجانب العسكري والجانب
النووي
انا متاكد ان انا نستطيع ان نتفق مع
الولايات المتحده عندما اتفقنا في عام
هل هذه الصفقه يمكن ان تفتحوا بابا لحوار
اعمق بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
باعتقادك
برنامج الولايات المتحده
مستعده لان تدخل في حوار مع روسيا الرئيس
بعد ان تحدث
عن ذلك قبل ايام ولكن بوتن كان قد رفض
شروط الحوار
بالمستوى العالي
قال انه لن يسحب القوات الروسيه من
اوكرانيا وعلينا ان نتحدث عن هذا
التبادل ومن الصعب ان يتخيل ان يكون له
انعكاس على الوضع في اوكرانيا
امكانيه اتمام هذه الصفقه هل تنتهي الامور
عند اطلاق سراح فيكتور بوت وبروك ام ان
هناك ما بعد ما جرى اليوم
اغنيه
انا اتفق مع زميلي
هذين بلدان
من اجل مصلحتي مواطنيهما
والبيت الابيض قال اليوم اننا سوف نستمر
مسجونين الامريكيين في روسيا
ونعم تستمر هذه المحادثات في مستوى معين
في مرحله ماء
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
تعد او بريتني جراينر احدى ابرز لاعبات
الرابطه الامريكيه لكره السله للسيدات
المحترفات حيث توجت بالقاب عده مع فريقها
والمنتخب الامريكي واللعبت على سبيل
الاعاره في اكثر من مناسبه مع فريق كره
سله روسي
[موسيقى]
والعرض التالي يعرفنا اكثر على رجل
الاعمال الروسي فيكتور بوت
[موسيقى]
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه سنستعرض ابرز
عمليات تبادل السجناء بين واشنطن
ونتناول مع ضيفنا سياقات هذا الاجراء وما
يمكن ان يقود اليه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات الداخليه
الالمانيه
وجه الضربه قويه لتنظيم المواطنين رايح
اضافه في مقابله مع قناه زي دي اف
الالمانيه ان اعضاء من التنظيم جاء من
الجيش الالماني و يمتلكون مهارات القوات
الخاصه فضلا عن امتلاكههم اسلحه من
مخزونات الجيش
كده يا باشا
كان ضربه قويه لمجموعه مواطن الرايخ
المسلحه والتي يبلغ عدد اتباعها 21000 شخص
ارتكبت هذه المجموعه اكثر من 1000 جريمه
العام الماضي ونحن نراقبها منذ ربيع هذا
العام وانا اعرف مخططاتها مجموعه مواطن
الرايخ مغرامه بالاسلحه والعديد من
افرادها يمتلكنا قانونيه او غير قانونيه
ومن مخزونات الجيش الالماني بعض المعتقلين
جاءوا من صفوف القوات المسلحه الالمانيه
ولديهم المهارات المناسبه من خلال خدمتهم
في الوحدات الخاصه العسكريه
وكانت سلطات الالمانيه اعلنت عن اعتقال 25
شخصا بينهم جنود سابقون ينتمون الى جماعه
من اقصى اليمين بتهمه الاعداد لاسقاط
الدوله وقالت الحكومه ان المجموعه كانت
تنوي لاستيلاء على السلطه بالقوه وان شاء
جيشا موازن وتنفيذ هجمات داخل المانيا
من برلين معنى مراسل الجزيره اسد الله
الصاوي مرحبا بك اسد كيف يتطور الوضع فيما
يتعلق بالمعلومات حول المخطط الذي كشف
وايضا باعتقالات انجرت او ينوي هناك نيه
بتنفيدها
نعمل هناك حاله من الترقب الشديد في اوساط
المجتمع
الالماني ووسائل حتى الاعلام الالمانيه
همم تستمر التحقيقات ومع استمرار
التحقيقات ترجح معلومات جديده مثل ما جاء
على لسان المسؤول في مخابرات الشرطه
الالمانيه اليوم عندما قال ان هذه
الجماعه جماعه مواطنه الرايخ
الكثير من اعضائها لديهم ميل لاستخدام
الاسلحه يقدر نحو 5% على الاقل من اعضاء
هذه الجماعه لديهم عدد كبير من همم
الاسلحه اذا ما قلنا ان الجماعه يعني كما
تقول الحكومه هي 21,000 شخص فهذا يعني على
الاقل 1,000 شخص مسلحون همم بشكل همم جيد
للغايه وهمم يعني انهم قادرون على استخدام
السلاح من المعلومات التي رجعت ايضا ان
هذه الجماعه لم تكن تنوي فقط مجرد يعني
همم شنه هجمات على سبيل السادس من يناير
في همم الولايات المتحده كما حدث في
الهجوم على الكونغرس وانما كانت تنوي
بالفعل الاستيلاء على السلطه وان هذا
المخطط بدا التخطيط له منذ نحوي عام وهذا
يضع الحكومه الالمانيه في موضع تسائلوا
انها حكومه اولاف شولتس تحتفل هذه الايام
بمرور العام الاول لها في السلطه بالطبع
كان عاما صعبا بسبب عده ظروف ابرازها
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ولكن هناك
ايضا تساؤلات الان همم اين كانت السلطات
كل هذا الوقت ولماذا تاخرت في التعامل مع
هذه الخليه حتى وصل الامر الى انه كانوا
على وشك تدبير محاوله انقلاب مكتمله
الاركان حسب تعبير الكثير من وسائل
الاعلام
الالمانيه وصحفيين المانيا كثر همم هذه
ما تشير الى ان اا الحكومه ربما همم او
هذه الارات تشير الى ان الحكم ربما تاخرت
في التحرك ضد هذه المجموعه وتثير ايضا
تساؤلات كيف تحصلت همم او تحصل اعضاء هذه
المجموعه على اسلحه كثيره من الجيش كما
قال مسؤولان امنيا كبيران همم اليوم كل
هذه المعلومات ما زالت في اطار التحقيقات
يتوقع الكثير من المعلومات في الايام
المقبله ويتوقع ايضا كما قال مسؤولا
كبيران في جهاز الامن الفدرالي الالمانيه
اليوم يتوقع ايضا المزيد من الاعتقالات من
المعلوم ان همم بالامس قام همم حوالي
ثلاثه الاف شرطي الماني بشن همم اعتقالات
همم ل 25 شخصا
ومداهمتي اا نحويه 150 مكانا في عموم
المانيا في ولايات كثيره كل هذه المعطيات
تثير حاله من
ربما اصبح في اوساط الالمان في انتظار
معلومات عن ماذا بالظبط يحدث
وكيف سيتم التعامل معهم من قبل السلطه
من برلين
للمزيد معنا من برلين دانيال بومر رئيسه
تحريري صحيفه ديفلت الالمانيه سيد دانيال
ماذا يكشف ما ظهر حتى الان من معلومات حول
هذا المخطط ماذا يكشف لك سياسيا
واستخباريا
احساس
هذا التطرف اليميني في المانيا الذي اسمه
مواطنه الريش والذي
يرفض مشروعيه
ديمقراطيه الحديثه في المانيا والحكومه
الالمانيه
لانهم في الاساس كانوا يريدون ان يعيد
الامبراطوريه
الالمانيه التي تعود الى 140 عام اذا لم
يكن احد يتعامل معهم بشكل جدي
وبعض سموا انفسهم همم امبراطور وملوك
دولتهم
المتخيله لكن الان يبدو
انهم يستعدون لانقلاب
وللقيام بهذا الانقلاب
وجمعوا ايضا
اناسا في مناصب
مهمه في السياسه
واذا للقضاء
منتسبي هذه المجموعات الذين جرع اعتقالهم
هم جنود سابقين وحصلوا على اسلحه يعني اا
تمكنوا من الحصول على اسلحه من مخازن
الجيش ما دلالات ذلك باعتقادك
والله العظيم
القلق اكثر من اي شيء اخر
هو ان هؤلاء الناس هم
اعضاء في الوحدات النخبه او الخاصه
المسؤوله عن
عمليات معقده ضد الارهاب
وكان هناك
تجاه هذه المجموعه في الماضي وهي تجمع كما
قلنا متطرفين
واعتقد ان الانطباع هنا في المانيا هو ان
بعض اعضاء الامن لم يكونوا يعونا او
يلونا قيمه كبيره لمعلومات المتوفره لديهم
لمحاوله التصدي لهم
طيب انت تحدثت عن انه لم يكن يتم التعامل
معهم بجديه في السابق ولكن هذه المجموعه
اليمنيه المتطرفه التي كشف عن مخططها في
المانيا
تتشارك بنفس الافكار ونفس الخلفيات مع
مجموعات يمنيه اخرى في اوروبا ما دلالات
ذلك ايضا باعتقادك ماذا يعني هذا بالنسبه
لحركه اليمين المتطرف في عمومه اوروبا
عايزين
يقول بانه هو تم
اصبحوا متطرفين
يبدو بشكل خاص في اوقات جارحه كورونا لانه
خلال فتره الاغلاق والقيود كان ذلك موضوعا
مهما بالنسبه لهذه المجموعه كان هناك عده
مظاهرات ضد تلك القيود
وكانوا حتى ينكرون ان يكون هناك
رائحه كورونا
واعتقد انه يبدو ان هذا الحدث قد وحد
بينهم
هناك عامل اخر وهو ان روسيا
كانت
تشجع المجموعات
المتطرفه
لكن في اوروبا
واعتقد ان هذا
ادى الى المعاناه التي رايناها او تصل في
ذروتها الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
كما انه من المهم ان نعرف ان
روسيا تقدم نفسها على انها شريكه لدول
الشرق الاوسط
لي اعاده دعم المتطرفين
والاحزاب الاسلاميه المتطرفه في جميع
انحاء اوروبا ايضا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الالمانيه من برلين
اكدت مصادر تركيه للجزيره ان الوفد
الروسيه عرض على تركيا انسحابه مقاتلين ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مع اسلحتهم
من عين العرب ومنبج اضافت المصادر التركيه
للجزيره ان العرض الروسي يقترح الابقاء
على قوات الاشايا الاسايش الكرديه بعد
دمجها في المؤسسه الامنيه للنظام وان
الوفد الروسي ابلغ الجانب التركي موافقه
ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على هذا
المقترح شريطه ضماني عدم حصول اجتياح
تركيه كما قالت المصادر التركيه للجزيره
ان انقر تدرس المقترحات التي قدمها الوفد
الروسي ولا تزال في مرحله النقاش بشانها
وفي تطورات العمليه العسكريه التركيه
الشماليه سوريا والعراق افادت مصادر محليه
للجزيره بان مدفعيه الجيش التركي قصفت عدد
من مواقع ما تعرف بقوه سوريا ديمقراطيه
قرب تلتمر في الحسكه ووفقا للمصادر
استهدفت طائره مسيره مواقع اخرى في محيط
عين عيسى شمال الرقه ياتي هذا في وقت قالت
فيهما تعرف بالاداره الذاتيه لشمال وشرق
سوريا انها ستنظم حمله على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه بهدف فرض حظر جوي في مناطقها
لوقف الهجمات التركيه حسب تعبيرها
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلنكن
ان لتركيا هواجس امنيه مشروعه ايذاء
انضمام السويد وفنلندا لحلف الناتو واشاد
بلنكن خلال مؤتمر صحفيا مشتركا مع نظيره
الفنلندي والسويدي في واشنطن بالخطوات
التي اتخذتها ستوكهولم واهل سينكي للحد من
مخاوف انقره الامنيه
وفنلندا
ارهابيه على الاراضي تركيا اكثر من اي بلد
اخر في حلف الناتو لكن انا نقدر الخطوات
الملموسه التي اتخذتها فنلندا والسويد بما
فيها تعزيز التعاون الثنائي بشكل كبير مع
تركيا بشان مخاوفها الامنيه الرئيسيه تمضي
هذه العمليه قدما بفضل العمل المهم للغايه
الذي قامت به في لندن والسويد مع تركيا
وتوقعوا ان تستمر العمليه وان تنتهي بنجاح
خلال 24 ساعه استشهد خمسه فلسطينيين واصيب
اخرون برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مناطق
مختلفه من الضفه الغربيه وقال الناطق
الرسمي باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيل ابو
ردينه انا حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تحاول اشعالا المنطقه من خلال مواصله
جرائمها ضد الشعب الفلسطيني من جهه تاكد
الناطق باسم حماس ان الجرائم الاسرائيليه
لن توقف نضال الشعب الفلسطيني بل ستزيده
اصرارا على مواصله المقاومه
عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه جديده استهدفت
مدينه ومخيمه جنين بالضفه الغربيه ادت الى
سقوط فلسطينيين برصاص قناصه لاحتلال الذين
اعتلوا بنايات وسط جنين دون ان تكون هناك
اشتباكات مسلحه في المكان وفق شهود عليها
ان وصلت الاسعاف مباشره
المقاومه الفلسطينيه باذرعها العسكريه
المختلفه اكدت انها تتصدى الاعتداءات
لاحتلال الاسرائيليين وانها تدافع عن
المخيم مهما كان الثمن المخيم محرم على
هذا الاحتلال ونحن جاهزون لمعركه مخيم
جنين كبرى جديده على ارض المخيم لننتقم
لكل دماء شهداء من الابرار التي يقوم
الاحتلال باستهداف شعبنا الفلسطيني في كل
مكان
ياتي تصعيد الاحتلال ومشاهد التشييع
اليوميه في وقت تؤكد فيه الحكومه
الفلسطينيه ان حكومه الاحتلال من خلال
تصريحات مسؤوليها المتطرفين وتهديداتهم
تحاول اشعادا المنطقه وتدفعها نحو مزيدا
من التوتر وتفجير الاوضاع
شعور
القتله الارهابيين همم بالافلات من العقاب
مستفيدين من سياسه المعايير المزدوجه همم
يشجعهم على ارتكاب المزيد من جرائمهم عدم
العقاب يعني ان جرائم خطيره اخرى قادمه في
الطريق وقد بلغت حصيله الشهداء في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه منذ بدايه هذا العام
215 بينهم اكثر من 55 شهيدا من محافظه
جنين ومخيمهامها
بين استمرار الاحتلال في سياسه قتل
الفلسطينيين والاعتقال والهدم والملاحقه
دون مسائله او محاسبه مواعيد المقاومه
بالثار لشهدائها تبقى المنطقه مرشحه لمزيد
من التصعيد الامني في ظل انسداد اي افق
سياسيه ينهي الصراع القائم سمير ابو شماله
الجزيره جنين فلسطين
يشكل المخيم وجنين مصدره قلق دائما لقوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نظرا لتنفيذ ابنائه
عددا كبيرا من عمليات المقاومه ويشون
الاحتلال هجمات متكرره على المخيم في
محاولاته لضرب بنيه المقاومه داخله لكنه
فشل في ذلك حتى الان
تقع محافظه جنين شمالي الضفه الغربيه
وتشكل منبثا للمقاومه الفلسطينيه ومصدر
قلق دائما للاحتلال الاسرائيلي ومدينه
جنين التي يقطن فيها نحو 46000 نسمه هي
مركز المحافظه وتكتسي مع مخيمها اهميه
الاستراتيجيه نظرا لموقعها اتبعدوا عن
مدينه القدس 75 كلم وعن الناصره 25 كم وعن
حيف 50 كلم وهذا الموقع وهو ما يجعل
الاحتلال لا يليها اهميه القصوى في
استراتيجته العسكريه ويبقى مخيم جنين
للاجئين الذي انشا عامه
53,000 مصدر القلق الاكبر للاحتلال لانه
حاضنه للمقاومه يقتن في المخيم الذي تبلغ
مساحته نحو كيلومتر مربع 16
مما يجعل الكثافه السكانيه فيه عاليه جدا
في عام 2002 اجتاحت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيمه في عمليه سمتها الصوره
الواقي لقي الاحتلال مقاومه شديده خلال
عمليه الاشتياح التي كلفته كثيرا اذ قتل
50 من جنوده وقد اعتقد الاحتلال انه قضى
على المقاومه في مخيم جنين بهذه العمليه
لكن المخيم لملم جراحه بسرعه وعاد ليؤرق
قوات الاحتلال وتنشط في المخيم قوات تابعه
لفصائل فلسطينيه عده منها الجناح العسكري
لحركه فتح كتائب شهداء الاقصى لواء
الشهداء وحركه الجهاد الاسلامي ممثله في
كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس ومن يميز
عمل هذه الفصائل في هذا المخيم هو
والالتحام والتازر والتنسيق مع نسبه عاليه
من الاستقلاليه في تنفيذ عملياتها ضد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من رام الله الدكتور
غسان الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه بيرزيت دكتور غسان في اسرائيل هناك
حكومه وشك على الانصراف بالتالي ما هي
الرسائل التي توجهها من وراء هذا التصعيد
الكبير بحق الفلسطينيين ولمن هي موجهه
اساسا
الذي شاهدنا نموذج له في هذا التقرير
مرشحه للاستمرار خصوصا على ضوء تركيبه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده الجيش
الاسرائيلي والمستوطنون الاسرائيليون ااه
يستمدون نفسا قويه من نتائج الانتخابات
الاسرائيليه
ويصعدون في محاوله لتهيه
اجواء ملائمه للاهداف السياسيه التي
تحملها هذه الحكومه الجديده لان هذه
الحكومه الجديده لديها اجنده سياسيه بعيده
المدى وتتطلب مقتضيات امنيه من نوع محدد
يحاول الجيش والمستوطنون التهيئه لمثل ذلك
يمكن ان ننتظر من الحكومه الجديده
بجناح المتطرف جدا الذي سيكون في داخلها
اعتقد بان هذه الحكومه سيكون لديها اهداف
استراتيجيه محدده اهمها تسريع وتيره
الاستيطان لحسم الامر على الارض فيما
يتعلق بسيطره المستوطنين على المساحات
الاكبر من الاراضي الفلسطينيه وثانيا
محاوله حسم الصراع الدائر في القدس وخصوصا
في البلده القديمه والمقدسات وبشكل خاص
المسجد الاقصى لانهم يسعون الى فرض واقع
جديد في سياق هذه الحكومه مرحله حكم هذه
الحكومه القادمه
والمساله الاخرى التي يجري الحديث عنها في
الاروقه السياسيه الاسرائيليه هي محاوله
تحويل السلطه الفلسطينيه من همم مشروع
سياسي لدوله فلسطينيه مستقبليه الى اا
اداره خدمتيه همم تخلو من اي بعد او طموح
سياسي هذه ملامح اوليه
الحكومه الجديده وهذه الاهداف حتى تتحقق
يجب ان يكون الو- الوضع الامني لمستوى
وهذا ما يشجع همم الحكومه الاسرائيليه من
خلال جيشها ومستوطنيها لمحاوله
خلق واقع امني تنعدم فيه او يعني
قمع المقاومه ونعمها من ان تلعب دور في
الشال هذا المخطط الاسرائيلي شكرا لك
دكتور غسان الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه بيرزيت من رام الله
عقدت في الرياض قمه ثنائيه صينيه سعوديه
حيث التقى الرئيس الصيني شيجن بينج
العائله السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
وشهدت القمه توقيع عدد من الاتفاقيات
ومذكرات التفاهم الثنائيه بين البلدين
وتجاوزت قيمه الاتفاقيات التي وقعت في 29
مليار دولار امريكي
وكان ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان والرئيس الصيني شجن قد عقد جلسه
مباحثات رسميه جرى خلال استعراض اوجه
التعاون بين البلدين والجهود التنسيقيه
المشتركه لتعزيز التعاون في مختلف
احتضنت الدوحه النسخ النسخه السادسه من
جائزه الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني الدوليه
للتميز في مكافحه الفساد وحضر هذه الفعليه
عدد من الشخصيات بينهم فولكاجامي رئيس
جمهوريه رواندا وجان انفنتينو رئيس
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم وثمن الفائزون
جائزه الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني الدوليه
للتميز في مكافحه الفساد واعتبروا انها
تساهم في دعم جهود المجتمع الدولي
والمؤسسات والافراد في محاربه افه الفساد
مراسلاتنا في الدوحه صار رشيد تنقل لنا
جانبا من تلك الفعليه
رفع الستار عن النسخه السادسه من النصب
التذكاري لجائزه الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني
الدوليه لمكافحه الفساد بالتعاوني مع
الامم المتحده في كورنيش الدوحه والذي
يرمز الى اليد الشفافه وخلال كلمه الرئيس
الرواندي في حفل الافتتاح اثناء على تنظيم
الذي وصفه بالرائع لكاس العالم وتطرق الى
الحمله الاعلاميه الشرسه التي واجهتها قطر
قبل انطلاق البطوله مؤكدا ان قطر تمكنت من
الرد بنجاحها حتى الان
الاموال التي استثمر
حكيما لمستقبال قطر والتي انتقادتها وسائل
الاعلام وقدمت شكاوي بشانها الا ان قطر
تمكنت من توجيه هذه الاستثمارات لبناء مدن
كالسيل التي ستعمل على التنميه لقرون وثمن
جهود امير الدوله قطر لدعمه جهوده مكافحه
الفساد وكذلك جهوده مقدره في استضافه كاس
العالم
سبع جوائز قدمت تكريما للافراد والمؤسسات
من منطلق المعايير وصفات في مجالات ابرزها
جائزه مستحدثه لحمايه الرياضه من الفساد
وتعد التنميه المستدامه من اهم اهداف هذه
الجائزه وهذا ما اكد عليه محامي الامم
المتحده لمكافحه الفساد علي بن فطيس المري
سمو الامير لم يخدم به وطنه فقط ولا امته
انا اعتقد ان التجاوز الامه الى ان يخدم
بها الانسانيه لانه بمحافظه على قضيه ااه
التنميه المستدامه عن طريق محاربه الفساد
هذه خدمه تقدم للانسانيه اللي تعاني من
هذه
النسخه الرابطه الدوليه لمكافحه الفساد
التيتها على الفائزين بالجائزه وسيكون ما
قارها فيينا وتعد هذه الجائزه بمثابه اداه
القطه على الاجراءات المثاليه والممارسات
الجيده على الصعيد العالمي لتحقيق تنميه
المستدامه والمكافحه اسباب الفساد عالميا
ادت دينا بولو ارتي نائبه رئيس بيرو بيدرو
كاسيو اليمين الدستوريه رئيسه انتقاليه
للبلاد بعد قرار البرلمان عزل الرئيس
كاسيو لتصبح اول امراه تتولى رئاسه بيرو
في تاريخها الحديث وتعهدت بولو ار تي
بتشكيل حكومه وطنيه جامعه ودعت اليه
سياسيه لتجاوز الازمه وكانت الشرطه اعتقلت
الرئيس كاسيو ووصفته بالرئيس السابق
معنى عاصمه الجزيره حسن مسعود حسان كيف
تبدو الاجواء في البلاد بعد تبول ورطه
منصب الرئاسه
قبل دقائق من الان وصلنا الى العاصمه
وصولنا ونحن نشعر بان الاوضاع هنا
في البلاد في العاصمه بعد وصول دين ابو
الورد الى الحكم وهي نائبه الرئيس المعزول
بيدرو كاسيو قبل قليل كانت تمر من هنا اا
بعض المسيرات المؤيده
للرئيس المعزول بيدرو كاسيو وهو الذي كان
قد نقل فجر اليوم الى السجن المركزي
لاتابع للشرطه همم في العاصمه همم ليما
بعدما كان متواجد في مقر المدينه البلديه
البلديه ليما وذلك بعد عزله من قبل
البرلمان ب101 صوت مقابل من اصل 130 صوتا
وذلك عقب اتخاذه لسلسله من القرارات كان
من بينها حل البرلمان وفرض حاله الطوارئ
وكذلك همم انشاء حكومه همم استثنائيه
وطارئه الى ان هذه القارات لم يتم تنفيذها
بشكل فعلي بعد ما عاجل البرلمان لعزل
الرئيس السابق هذه
الازمه الحديثه واا هي تعتبر من بين همم
سلسله من الازمات التي كانت تمر بها
الفروق وذلك بعد ما كان قد مر على اثير
منذ عام 2018 وحتى الرئيس الحاليه دينا
ابو الورد ست رؤساء خلال اربع سنوات فقط
من همم حكم البلاد خلال الفتره الماضيه
وهو ما يشير الى الواقع السياسي وازمه
الحكم التي تعاني منها البيرو وذلك نتيجه
لسلسله من الازمات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
وكذلك الدستوريه والقانونيه التي كانت تمر
بها البيرو منذ استعاده الديمقراطيه فيها
وهمم وهذا ياتي ايضا
ظلي احتجاجات واحتجاجات مضاده احتجاجات
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل مؤيده للرئيس المعزول
كاسيو واحتجاجات اخرى معارضه له ومؤيده
لمحاكمته بتهم الفساد وكذلك بتهم محاوله
الانقلاب شكرا جزيلا لك من ليما مراسلنا
حسن مسعود
[موسيقى]
الى عمليات تبادل السجناء بين واشنطن
وموسكو هذه ليست الاولى من نوعها بل كانت
ظاهره بارزه في علاقات الجانبين على مدى
العقود الماضيه في فبراير عام 1962 جرت
صفقه تبادل للسجناء بين الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد السوفيتي ان ذلك اذ اطلقت واشنطن
صراحه عميلا للمخابرات السوفياتيه مقابل
اطلاق تيارا امريكي قبض عليه حين سقط
التيارته داخل خلال مهمه استطلاع في ابريل
من عام اربعه 64 اطلق سراح رجل اعمال
بريطاني سجناء بتهمه التجسس لصالح
بريطانيا والولايات المتحده مقابل اطلاقه
في الجيش الروسي سجنته بريطانيا بتهمه
التجسس بهدف الحصول على معلومات من
الغواصات البريطانيه في يونيو عام 85
وافقت الولايات المتحده والاتحاد السوفيتي
انذاك على اكبر عمليه تبادل الاستجناء في
ذلك الوقت
قد واشنطن بموجبها صراحه ثلاثه عملاء
بينهم الجاسوس البولندي الشهير مريم
ذاكرتي الذي سرق تكنولوجيا عسكريه وذلك
مقابل افراج السوفيات عن ثلاثه وعشرين
سجينه اطلق السوفيات في فبراير عام 86
صراحه المعارض اليهودي سوفيتي اناتولي
شرانسكي المتهم بالتجسس لصالح الغرب مقابل
الافراج عن تسعه اشخاص متهمين او مدنين
بالتجسس لصالح السوفيات
هذا بالنسبه لفتره لفتره الحرب البارده
لكن ماذا عن احدث عمليات تبادل السجناء
بين روسيا وامريكا من ابرزها ما جرى في
يوليو تموز عام 2010 افجرت صفقه تبادل
جواسيس بين واشنطن وروسيا في مطار فيينا
اطلق بموجبها سراح 10 جواسيس روس مقابل
الافراج عن اربعه مواطنين سجنوا في روسيا
بتهم التجسس لصالح الغرب في ابريل الماضي
تبادل البلدان سجناء بواسطه تركيه اطلق
بموجبها سراح جنديا امريكيا السابق مقابل
اطلاقا الامريكيين صراحه مواطنا روسي كان
يقضي عقوبه بالسجن 20 عاما في قضيه تهريب
مخدرات
اجمالا تعلقت عمليات التبادل هذه بقضايا
على راسها التجسس بهدف الحصول اما على
معلومات عن التكنولوجيا العسكريه او
الالكترونيه او معلومات متعلقه بالصواريخ
او الفضاء او غيرها للمزيد حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور
خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث بالمركز العربي
في ورشه مرحبا بك دكتور خليل اذا عمليات
التبادل همم تتم منذ تاريخ طويل بين
الولايات المتحده
وروسيا ولكن ماذا تقول لنا عندما تحدث
في فتره يكون فيها العلاقات همم يسودها
توتر شديد كما هو حاصل اليوم
حضرتك بس ده مشاهدين تقول لنا انه رقم كل
الصعوبات الموجوده وكل هذه التوترات هناك
قناه خلف
الروس والطرف الامريكي نعلم جميع انه هذه
المساله مساله شركه تماما لان مستمر
العكس والعكس صحيح كل امريكا روسيا ويعتبر
مجتهد حتى يثبت العكس وبالتالي وجود هذا
النوع من المفاوضات من خلف الستار يعني
بانه هذه المساله عما يجري من خلال صراعات
سياسيه واستراتيجيه كما يحل الان في الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا طيب الصفقه صفقه
التبادل التي حصلت اليوم بريتني جراينر
مقابل فيكتور بوت باعتقادك ما الذي يمكن
ان يستتبعها
انا اعتقد جزء ده متعلق به اصبحت هذه قضيه
راي عام جرينر هي لعبه سله الامريكيه
هيظهر على بدايه ثاني ذهبيتين اولمبيتين
وبالتالي هي كانت محل راي عام خاص تم
اعتقادها على خلفيه شيء قد يكون باسم راي
الامريكي شيء تافه تماما يعني هناك
اقل من جرام من الحشيش او همم نبات الحشيش
وبالتالي هناك راي عام كان ضاغط على
امريكا لكن نقطه مهمه جدا متعلقه بعدم ضم
الصفقه الحاليه واحد من اهم المعتقلين
الامريكان في روسيا وهو همم بول وهو تم
اعتقاله في 2018 هو ضابط سابق للجيش
الامريكي واخذ حكم حوالي 16 عام داخل
روسيا حتى لحظه وبالتالي هناك في حاله
خيبه امل داخل امريكا في عدم هذه الصفقه
التي تمت اليوم همم
اضافه امريكا وبالتالي همم الموضوع الان
هو موضوع راي عام لحد بعيد هناك فرح
بالافراج بصراحه
بتعمل في الفشل بصراحه
كلمات يعني من يتحمل مسؤوليات الفشل في
اطلاق بول ويلان هل ان الطرف الروسي هو
الذي امتنع ام ان الجانب الامريكي يعتبر
ان بريتني جراينر يعني
بروفايل كبير اكثر في همم في داخل الاعلام
ربما
متعدده اربع سنوات من قبل امريكا من اجل
اطلاق سراحويل لكنه على ما يبدو هناك
تعامل تلوث الى حد بعيد هناك اعتقاد روسي
لان هو من ناحيه العمليه والفعليه هو اكثر
اهميه ضربه في الجيش الامريكي فانا في
سلاح المريء يعتبر هو سيد مقارنه بجرينا
التي لا تعده يعني لها اهميه كره الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه وبالتالي هناك تعامله روسي
امريكا
محاوله اخرى مستمره هناك باحضار للمراه
الاخرى الى امريكا
ما هو المتوقع خصوصا وان البيت الابيض
يقول لا شيء سيتغير بالنسبه لسياسه
الامريكيه همم فيما يتعلق بدعم اوكرانيا
كما قلت قبل قليل الملف السجناء او تبادل
السجناء ملف منفصل تماما عن ملف الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كما نعلم جميعا نحن
جزاء حرب على مدار 10 شهور هناك داعم
امريكي واسع جدا دعم عسكري دعم استخبارات
ودعم لوجستي وبالتالي هناك فصل تم من هذه
الملفات ملف السجناء شيء وملف الحرب روسيا
على قناه شيء اخر بدل ملف حتى النفوذ
الروسي في المنطقه بشكل عام هو ملف ايضا
همم ليس له علاقه بالتبادل السبان تبادل
السبانخ موجود مستمر من على الاقل سبعه
عقود كان جاء في الفقير قبل قليل كان جاء
في عرض حضرتك قبل قليل هناك تبادل مستمر
سوف الحرب البارده الحرب البارده وبالتالي
كاس الملك علاقه بين الامرين هناك في فصل
بين الامرين بين الملف السجناء من الجهه
وملف الصراع الجوز استراتيجي والاقتصادي
والعسكري بين روس امريكا من جهه اخرى
اشكرك همم الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والباحث بالمركز العربي في واشنطن ضيفنا
من الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا موجز
لاهم الانباء قبل الانتقالي الى يوميات
المونديال توصلت واشنطوا الى صفقه لتبادل
السجناء
الافراج عن لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه
بريتني جرايدر التي كانت محتجزه في روسيا
واطلاق سراح رجل الاعمال الروسي فيكتور
بوت وظهرت صور كل من جراينر روبوت بعد
اطلاقهما وهما في طريقهما الى بلديهما
ووعد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بالعمل على
اطلاقه محتجزين امريكيين اخرين وقالت
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم جامبير
ان التفاوض كان مباشره بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا من اجل الافراج عن بريتاني
ولم تكن هناك اي وساطه واشارت الى ان
الامارات العربيه المتحده سالت استخدام
اراضيها لاتمام عمليات التبادل
قالت الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان معظم
منتسبي تنظيم المواطنين رئيس الذين اعلنت
عن اعتقالهم في اطار مخطط للاستيلاء على
السلطه كانوا جنود سابقين وانا لديهم
اسلحه من مخزونات الجيش وقد داهمت الشرطه
150 موقعا في مختلف مناطقي المانيا
اكدت مصادر تركيه للجزيره ان الوفد الروسي
عرض على تركيا انسحابه مقاتلين ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مع اسلحتهم من
عين العرب ومنبج اضافت المصادر للجزيره ان
العرض الروسي يقترح الابقاء على قوه
الاسايش الكرديه بعد دمجها في المؤسسه
الامنيه للنظام وان الوفد الروسي ابلغ
الجانب تركي موافقه ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه على هذا المقترح شريطه ضمان
عدم حصول اجتياح تركي
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
خمسه فلسطينيين منهم اثنان في رام الله
وثلاثه اخرون في جنين بالضفه الغربيه وقال
شهود عيان ان جنود الاحتلال اطلقوا النار
على الشهداء الثلاثه قرب الميدان الرئيسي
لمدينه جنين افاد مراسل الجزيره ان قوات
الاحتلال اعتقلت في جنين ضابطه امن واسيرا
محررا
نهايه الحصاد شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]